[Music]
okay so all gripes against spider-man
three aside we still love Sam Raimi's
trilogy for it's heartfelt take on the
amazing wall brawler the studio
basically made him shoehorn venom into
the third movie overruling his wishes to
make Sandman its only villain and
ruining the chances for spider-man 4 but
thanks to some concept art by storyboard
artist Jeffrey Henderson we can see that
Spidey would have taken on the vulture
and Mysterio
if Raimi had managed to hang around for
a fourth movie that is busting Mysterio
the storyboard concept art for Mysterio
doesn't really show a fight between him
and Spidey but we can imagine how great
it might have been Mysterio mainly uses
special effects illusions hypnotism and
theatrics so we may not have been too
serious of a threat compared to the rest
of spider-man's foes at unmasked
Mysterio at the police station looks
kinda like Bruce Campbell right given
Rama's longtime friendship with Campbell
it would have been the perfect casting
the Evil Dead star appears in all three
spider-man movies that Raimi directed
first he was the announcer who named
Peter Parker spider-man then he was the
snooty theater usher in the sequel and
he finally played the French restaurant
maitre d in spider-man 3 we can almost
imagine mysterious backstory just based
on Campbell's three appearances in the
previous spider-man films he wanted to
get into show business but had to settle
as a lowly wrestling announcer then he
tried to work in theater but never made
it as a result he became an usher when
that didn't work out he ultimately
resorted to a restaurant gig where he
used his acting skills to fake a French
accent in a bind for cash he stole a
bunch of special-effects equipment for a
robbery becoming Mysterio only to be
busted by spider-man how great would it
have been to see Maguire and Campbell
facing off one last time the vulture
takes flight these storyboards seem to
the vulture seem a lot more serious and
telling the mysterious suggesting that
he may have been the movie's main
villain you can see him reaching for a
helicopter and taking on spider-man in
the skies above New York and it looks
like the vulture suit is very much in
sync with the characters original comic
book outfit this is pretty different for
the first villain of the Spidey movies
Willem Dafoe's Green Goblin who has a
modernized looking pair of the source
material well what do you think what a
fourth movie have righted the wrongs of
spider-man 3 or where the vulture and
Mysterio of in the final fall for Tobey
Maguire spider-man
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
who you think should have played
spider-man for his villains
[Music]
you